Today there are about 25 countries
without an army,
but I'll ask you which one of them was
fast?
Which country do you think was the first
he voluntarily give up its armed forces.
If you guys do European country,
you're not even on the right continence.
It was actually a Latin American country
and that was of course Costa Rica on
December the first 19,
48 after a civil war under president and
Jose Figueroa.
As Fair as administration,
Costa Rica puts an end to its military
career and you know what?
This wasn't actually a bad mood.
Send the country hasn't had a single
wall or a single key.
In fact,
Costa Rica can boast about being the
country with the longest,
uninterrupted period of democratic
governments in Latin America because Dvo
north again,
to the enormous way that the military
boot has traditionally had on last and
American.
Okay.
Then there's the fact that Costa Rica is
located in one of the most violent
regions in the world.
Central America.
Okay.
Despite this,
this tropical country located between
the Caribbean sea and the Pacific Ocean
has managed to become a middle income
country with quite high levels of
prosperity.
So what's the recipe here?
Well,
prosperity,
peace and safety.
These are the ingredients that have made
Costa Rica habitually known as the
Switzerland of Latin in America.
Now,
what is true in all of this,
and in this video we want to tell you a
bit more about Costa Rica.
We want to have a look good.
It's light,
but also at its shadows.
So let's dive in.
Just a happy face,
however we look at it.
Costa Rica is a very special country.
Divya,
we're talking about a country whose
hallmark color is green because of Costa
Rica is associated with anything.
It's bio diverse.
You see with an area that's almost 10
times smaller than that of Spain or 25
times smaller than Peru.
This country is estimated to have more
than five percent of all the world's
animal and plant biodiversity in this
country.
They understand this is not just a sign
of identity,
but also a potentially great competitive
advantage,
for example,
among other things.
It can help develop a differentiated
tourism industry and position a strong
country brands that is to say,
one that gives high value to local
products,
especially for international,
yeah,
because they wouldn't be willing to pay
a bit more for products considered to be
produced cleanly in an environmental
haven and Costa Rica and while they take
these policies very,
very seriously,
Costa Rica strives to be an ecological
power is it absolutely is more than 25
percent of national territory is
protected and the vast majority of
electricity comes from renewable
sources,
hydroelectric,
geothermal and wind power,
and not only that,
Costa Rica is the only country in the
region.
Man's one of the few in the world that
has managed to reverse deforestation.
The territory covered by forests has
increased from 21 percent in 1987 to
over 50 percent in the present.
The thing that,
by the way,
they achieved thanks to a curious
payment system for environmental
services.
Allow me to explain this.
In Costa Rica,
a part of the taxes on fuels goes to
funds at Costa Rican forest financing or
funds that pays farm and forest owners.
He wants to join the program voluntarily
to conserve their natural space and
implement projects that help strengthen
it and that's not all.
Many companies also pay into this fund
to offset their impacts on the
environment.
Something like corporate social
responsibility that's promoted by the
states.
Now I think this leads to a really
interesting debate because for some this
policy is a bit of a monstrosity,
whereas for others it will be a way of
recognizing the negative externalities
of productive activities such as the
pollution caused by factories and also
of course there's the positive
externalities.
All natural areas,
half of our territory is covered by
forest and we have an apple system of
protected areas that not only protect an
important part of the planet's
biodiversity,
but also sustain important sectors of
our economy.
As for example,
tourism.
Carlos Alvarado,
president of Costa Rica.
Personally,
I believe that if these types of
initiatives are accompanied by policies
that promote the creation of companies
and new types of businesses,
they could be really successful.
But let's leave it open to debate.
You can let us know what you think of
all of this in the comments,
but now let's move on.
The fact is that this type of political
approach doesn't seem to have been at
odds with the country's economic growth
since the year 2000.
The Costa Rican economy has grown by
around four percent every year,
which even if it doesn't seem like much
has been a higher average growth rate
than that of the rest of Latin America
and the OACD countries.
Yes,
and that's not all Costa Rica is
undergoing something similar to what we
saw with New Zealand's.
If we measure variables besides GDP,
for example,
if we consider life expectancy,
salaries and situation of companies,
et Cetera,
I think Costa Rica comes out even
better.
Take a look at the the Gotham prosperity
index and the ranking of countries by
GDP per capita in purchasing power
parity.
That is taking price differences into
account.
If we do,
we'll notice the Costa Rica is GDP per
capita is the sixth laundries didn't
last in America.
That is,
it's below Chile,
Panama,
Uruguay,
Argentina and Mexico and 76 in the
wells.
In the global prosperity index,
Costa Rican rises to the 29th place
being the second country in Latin
America,
closely behind,
if you want some clear proof,
the average life expectancy in Costa
Rica is the third highest in the entire
American continents.
Being higher,
for example,
then the last of the United States,
Costa Rica,
it looks like a prosperous,
peaceful country,
committed to the preservation of the
environment,
which all sounds pretty great,
right?
Well,
hold on for a moment because this
country has another face.
Costa Rica is facing very complicated
challenges,
so listen up challenges that threatened
the country.
Costa Rica is a country that has
achieved great things,
especially if we can pair this with many
of its neighbors.
However,
right now it's facing political,
economic,
and social challenges that threaten its
path to prosperity.
The first one,
clearly it's got a lot to do with the
economy.
See,
even though Costa Rica has had a solid
performance,
it still has a long way to go.
Currently its GDP per capita is just
over 40 percent of the average for the
country.
Yes.
Here's the problem.
The last government was,
how do you want to say it,
a bit irresponsible with their fiscal
policy,
which left Costa Rica in a rather
delicate situation only in the last 10
years.
The public debt has more than doubled in
terms of GDP for 2018.
Deficit will approach is seven percent
and one of every $3 of public spending
will go towards paying that debt.
While in 2008 taxes finance,
70 percent of all central government
expenditures in 2017,
they were only enough to finance 50
percent and the difference had to be
covered with debtedness Jorge corellas
consider.
Fortunately,
that seems to be a political consensus.
If the situation doesn't change,
Costa Rica could face several problems,
but mainly focusing on raising taxes
could also be counter productive.
The country's tax on corporate profits
is already one of the highest in the
world.
It's not only taxes.
For example,
the cost of electricity and fuel,
which lies in the hands of public
monopolies are among some of the most
expensive in the region,
which obviously affects competitive.
Yes,
increases like these.
The labor participation rates,
the rate of people who work is really
rather low.
The president's call us Alvarado really
needs to open up the economy and allow
competition and if possible,
set apart so that the large public
companies can be shared by Costa Rican.
The second challenge has to do with
violence.
In recent years,
violence has grown and loss in a country
that was traditionally very safe and
very quiet and well.
This does have a simple explanation.
Drug traffickers,
Yup.
As you may already know,
drug traffickers are ravaging a large
parts of Latin America and now they're
trying to extend influence to Costa
Rica,
which is a good path for that much and
dice third,
well,
the third challenge has a lot to do with
politics.
The last elections were a good example
of how radical and populist messages
that targets civil liberties are a great
threat.
See the first electoral rounds held in
February.
It wasn't one by Carlos Alvarado this by
for Bricio Alvarado and evangelist
pastor,
who has a very radical discourse among
his obsessions with pursuing any
societal model that differed from what
he perceived as convenient,
especially anything related to equal
marriage,
and of course anyone can see what they
want and lead their lives however they
please,
but when a politician wants the
government to keep devoted itself to
religion and persecute those who don't
agree with their life model,
it can become really dangerous.
Is Laura Musca.
Fabrizio Alvarado,
his wife in the middle of their campaign
and don't try and tell me that she's not
scary.
Generally in the second round,
this evangelical pastor who's speech had
a lot of hatred and varied as a loved
suffered,
a crushing defeat even though he still
won 30 percent of the votes,
but it's this sort of populism that
Costa Rica is going to have to be very
careful within the future,
but it's if view.
That's kind of the way things are.
Carlos Alvarado has just been elected
president and it's now in his hands to
get Costa Rica back on track.
To achieve this,
you'll have to change a lot of things
and don't forget that the best way to
fight poverty is by promoting more
dynamic,
open and competitive economies.
Companies are new question going to have
to play a prominent role in order
of this,
but now I see.
What do you think that Costa Rica is?
Green model is one other countries
should follow.
Do you think the Costa Rica itself is a
model to follow?
Well,
leave your answers in the comments as
well as in this survey and I really hope
you enjoyed this video.
Please do hit that like button if you
did and don't forget to subscribe to our
channel for brand new videos every
Monday and every Thursday we'll say,
don't forget to check it.
Our friends at the reconsider media
podcast,
they provided the vocals in this episode
that weren't not mine,
and as always,
thank you for watching.